hey what is going on Oh God Oh nice
intro doo doo doo doo Oh what is going
on YouTube you [ __ ] cute little crumb
bums yeah I like the way that word
sounds it's cute now recently on this
plan of diving and eating healthier
I get urges I get the urge to eat [ __ ]
that's been me because I miss the
[ __ ] flavors McDonald's [ __ ] spots
or me watch it but uh please mother me
huh come on
but you ever had that one friend that
says something so stupid when you're
trying to eat healthier that you want to
take a rock and smash their kneecaps
just me cuz the other day I was counting
my macros correctly and I wanted to eat
a cheeseburger so I grabbed one but when
I did my friend lifia said dude why do
you even want that [ __ ] have you even
tried a vegan burger it tastes just like
a cheeseburger the [ __ ] you just say to
me oh no he didn't he got me high the
worst thing you could do to a fat man is
tell him some fake [ __ ] about food
when he's hungry what you think I'm
stupid don't say stupid [ __ ] like it
tastes just like a cheeseburger what
what what who are you fooling
this stupid hurts my friend I don't know
what to do and then you know that well
you're vegan tofurkey burger tastes like
hot ass
tell me tastes just like a cheeseburger
[ __ ] I'm a grown-ass [ __ ] man talk
to me like I'm a child at the hospital
we trying to give him a shot and you
trying to pull the me [ __ ] look [ __ ] I
see the needle hey you know what the
funny [ __ ] is the moment that life flew
out of his ugly-ass face even he knew he
was [ __ ] his left eye was twitching
like this Helena listen I'm not saying
that other alternatives to the things
that you want couldn't possibly taste
great that's not true at all it might
taste pretty good but that's not what I
want right now and you know people get
things twisted too just because people
are fat doesn't mean that they don't
like healthy options I love vegetables
I'll eat that big burger patty when I
want to but that's not what I won't at
this moment you know what veggie patties
look like veggie patties look like Dukie
that came out of a living trees [ __ ]
you see cuz I've heard everything about
these veggie boca patties ahead
thirty-six different ingredients and it
tastes just like me right I got it
somehow you managed to turn dirt beans
and Dukey into something that looks like
B what but what I want you to do is to
take that frankenburger freeze it and
especially on your teeth you know what
the ingredients in my beef burger patty
is delicious not be delicious
look at me like I'm crazy because my
real cheeseburger tastes better than
your fake cheeseburger and what's wrong
with you
it's all natural David your foods
processed whatever [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] you talking to the wrong person
cows are natural too which is why they
naturally change good ten listen since
we're on the topic stop sending me
articles about how bad McDonald's is for
you [ __ ] we all know that [ __ ]
there's not a single person denied that
fast-food burgers just might be bad for
to your buddy that's not something
that's unique to McDonald's nobody goes
to McDonald's thinking it's time to get
healthy hahaha
their slogan is but I find but fine I'm
madder not for that five by five we
taste like [ __ ] it's for the flavor on
the price it can't be be some people are
in a position where they shouldn't be
saying [ __ ] about the stuff that you
eating the other day I was eating this
filet-o-fish and this random dude came
up to me and said excuse me baby but you
know that she's bad for you I turn
around this [ __ ] was smoking a crack
pipe
what about don't cut yourself now with
now recently a [ __ ] my childhood now
wait at the i'mma tell you something
watch this but I file such a dick